my name is patricia jones byrd and i am
the proud teacher of fourth grade
reading language arts at plummer
elementary school in cedar hill texas i
am 66 years old in spite of my age i
suit up every day and i do the work with
fidelity and with vibrancy i have been
an educator for 38 years
13 of those years have been at the
classroom teacher level in addition to
that i have served as an assistant
principal then as a principal and i was
superintendent at the charter school
system until 2016 and i decided to
retire my husband and i have been
married for 43 years and he and i have a
daughter throughout my career my husband
has been my greatest champion
when my husband was diagnosed with
cancer in 2016 i knew that i had to
return to work to help fund the cost of
his cancer care and his treatments it
wasn't rocket science that i provide the
same level of support for him in his
time of need that he has provided for me
and i ended up at plumber and i have no
regrets whatsoever
lawrence is doing well the cost of the
medication continues to challenge our
finances but i went back for the right
reason what i enjoy most about teaching
the reason that i'm here is to influence
the trajectory of the lives of scholars
[Music]
hi everybody
how are you how are you
i'm so happy to be here with you guys
we've been prepping for this for weeks
and just so excited to celebrate
patricia
thank you and where is lauren patricia's
daughter
hi lauren so your mom has been a teacher
longer than you've been alive yes she
has and so it kind of reminds me of that
song if you are my sunshine like she's
everybody's sunshine it doesn't matter
if you're the custodian it doesn't
matter if you're the principal it
doesn't matter who you are everybody
matters and she's taught that to so many
people where do you think she learned it
from i think she learned it from her
family she had 13 brothers and sisters
and so she appreciates every little
thing and she wants kids that are
without to feel like they matter and
that they can succeed and they will as
long as you just put some hard work into
it so that's my dad
what was it like in your family
going through something like that
i'm so sorry how scary
how did she manage to teach and take
care of you at the same time once you
know pat she's driven
and once she commits to something she's
going to finish it through
and who here has a nephew that studied
with her yes
when i chose to bring my nephew to live
with me he was in a situation where he
was in a high crime written neighborhood
he had already been held back a grade
patricia byrd is
a five-foot giant her intentions her
focus her
compassion and sincere care for people
is immeasurable when my nephew left that
grade with her
he spoke a new tune saying a new song
and his aspirations are higher than i
could imagine so i'm indebted to her we
just so admire patricia
and everything she's doing now
i guess we're going to surprise her
she has no idea
i love that
i'm also going to go get on the pa
system oh wow
what do you guys suggest i say on the pa
system what would make patricia go
what's happening eat it in the front
office right away please right away okay
urgency she follows instructions and
should i call her mrs bird or patricia
bird mrs mrs byrne
perfect
all right
and so basically the author used all
cats notice that all cats
mrs bird you are needed in the front
office right away mrs bird you are
needed in the front office right away
not sure what that's all about
i'll be back as quickly as i can okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you